الترقب في الزهور في
متناول اليد ، ينتظرون بفارغ الصبر هذا هو
الوقت الأكثر إثارة خلال ثلاث سنوات في
مطارات الصين حيث تعيد البلاد فتح
حدودها
وفي اللحظة التي تصل فيها أخيرًا ، هذه
لم الشمل ذات مغزى بشكل خاص
لأول مرة منذ بداية
المسافرين الوباء  من الخارج يمكنهم مقابلة
عائلاتهم مباشرة بعد
النزول من الطائرة بدلاً من إرسالهم إلى
منشأة الحجر الصحي
، فالأم وابنها ينتظران
زوجها والده في المطار
لم يروا بعضهما البعض منذ ما يقرب من عام ،
نعم أنا حقًا  متحمس لقد مر
وقت طويل ، لقد كنت خجولًا بعض الشيء ، لكنه يقول إنه
يفتقد والده والزهور لعائلة
والده الذين
يركضون لاستقبال والده الذي حصل
أخيرًا على هذا العناق الدافئ ،
فقد
عاد مطار العاصمة بكين الدولي أخيرًا إلى الحياة
ولكن كما  الصين تنفتح
على دول أخرى تتوتر أكثر
من اثنتي عشرة دولة فرضت
قواعد اختبار كوفيد -19 على المسافرين القادمين
من الصين.  لقد قطعت محاولات مثل كوريا
الجنوبية خطوة أبعد من ذلك ، حيث توقفت عن
إصدار تأشيرات قصيرة الأجل من
قنصلياتها في الصين
، والانتقام من بكين ،
علقت الآن إصدار تأشيرات قصيرة الأجل
للكوريين الجنوبيين.حتى أن
المغرب قد حظر المسافرين من
الصين
ولم يعلن رسميًا إلا عن بضع عشرات من الأشخاص
المرغوب فيهم.  وفيات منذ إعادة الافتتاح ، لكن
صور الأقمار الصناعية تكشف عن قصة مختلفة ، تظهر
هذه الصور التي التقطت في أواخر
ديسمبر وأوائل يناير حشودًا
في محارق الجثث في الصين وطوابير طويلة
من السيارات تنتظر خارج دور الجنازات
في ست مدن صينية
، ويبدو أن الصور تظهر أن منزل جنازة
في الضواحي  لقد
شيدت بكين حتى ساحة انتظار سيارات جديدة تمامًا
قمنا بزيارة محرقة جثث في وسط المدينة
الشهر الماضي تظهر الحشود
وظهور الجثث تتراكم في صناديق معدنية
لكن الانفجار وحالات الطمع لا
تمنع الناس من السفر إلى الخارج أه إلى
أين أنت ذاهب إلى اليمين  الآن هل أنت
متحمس لأنك لست مضطرًا إلى الحجر الصحي
بعد الآن ،
إنها دول جيدة جدًا
مثل تايلاند  من
أجل التعزيز الاقتصادي ، الترحيب بالمجموعة الأولى
من السياح الصينيين بالورود
في المطار
والمزيد من المسافرين الصينيين في
طريقهم إلى مكاتب الهجرة في جميع أنحاء
البلاد مع تدفق السكان الذين
يصطفون لتقديم طلب للحصول على وثائق السفر في
جميع أنحاء البلاد ، جميع الحدود البرية للصين
لديها  أعاد السكان فتح
أبوابهم وهتفوا باللحظة التاريخية ، لكن المزاج الاحتفالي تضاءل بسبب الانتشار الهائل للفيروس ، لم يكن النظام الطبي مستعدًا
للانعطاف المفاجئ للبلاد بعيدًا
عن فيروس كورونا ، لكنها لحظة مؤثرة
لجميع هذه العائلات في
المطار بعد سنوات من التضحية  خلال
xero covid أخيرًا تم لم شمل
سيلينا وانغ سي إن إن بكين